like so many u.s
towns the covid pandemic has brought
businesses in delaware county
pennsylvania
economic uncertainty and even collapse
a lot of us small businesses are
interdependent of each other so as one
business ails
we all feel it michael gibbons has been
running a small automotive repair shop
in delaware county
that employs seven people last year the
government stimulus
helped keep his business running
but he's less certain about president
joe biden's promise of new aid
and what it means for him there's a lot
of questions that americans need answers
to you look at some of these big
stimulus bills and there's a lot of
what you would call pork in them that's
exactly why biden visited this flooring
business
in delaware county to highlight the
benefits of his 1.9
trillion dollar american rescue plan
that last week he signed into law
the plan includes 14-hundred dollar
checks for individuals
and help for small businesses biden
staking his presidency on his relief
package to stop
america's jobs crisis it's also intended
to repair local government finances
and address issues of poverty and
inequality
100 million people are going to be
getting not a joke
a check for fourteen hundred dollars
changed their life
it's the biggest enhancement of
america's social safety net in decades
being rolled out like a nation at war
in addition to biden vice president
kamala harris
her husband doug emhoff and first lady
dr jill biden
are crisscrossing the united states to
promote the rescue plan's benefits
it's a big gamble the biden
administration is hoping to create an
explosion of economic
activity without triggering inflation on
main streets
just like this one all across the united
states
but business owners like michael gibbons
are skeptical of the plan
and whether all that money will go to
those that really need it
there's a lot of americans out there
that for whatever reason have a general
mistrust of government
and so yes joe biden has a lot of work
in front of them to kind of bridge those
gaps and get this country back online
national polls show the american rescue
plan is popular
but biden is not taking it for granted
his administration knows it needs to
deliver relief to america's
main street quickly in order for it to
be
a success kimberly helge at al jazeera
delaware county pennsylvania